die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis guten abend und
herzlich willkommen alles wichtige vom
sport erfahren sie von norbert lehmann
sophie schauen wir auf die themen des
tages
mit steigender inzidenz in den herbst
bund und länder einigen sich auf neue
chor ohne regeln und für die opfer der
flut auf 31 milliarden fonds für den
wiederaufbau
die lokführer streiken es werden zwei
schwierige tage für bahnreisende
urlauber und pendler
klares ziel und hoher anspruch hansi
flick fordert bei seinem ersten auftritt
als bundestrainer die rückkehr an die
weltspitze
die korona schnelltests müssen die
meisten bald selber zahlen und für
ungeimpfte gibt es eine neue testpflicht
dem minister präsidentinnen und
präsidenten haben sich heute mit der
kanzlerin auf neue corona maßnahmen
geeinigt und auf einen wiederaufbau
fonds für die flutgebiete auf den
schauen wir gleich erst einmal die neuen
corona beschlüsse im überblick an seinem
stern
deutschland bleibt formal im virus
krisenmodus bund und länder wollen die
sogenannte epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite noch eine ganze
weile verlängern das ist die grundlage
für viele corona regeln bei denen sich
einiges ändert die kostenlosen
schnelltests für alle werden abgeschafft
ab dem elften oktober menschen die sich
impfen lassen können und es nicht tun
müssen dann selbst zahlen und tests
werden sie brauchen da wo die korona
situation schlechter ist also in der
regel die inzidenz über 35 liegt müssen
viele ungeimpfte ab dem 23 august einen
aktuellen negativen corona test
vorweisen und zwar für besuche in
krankenhäusern altenheimen hotels und
auch fitnessstudios und auch im
restaurant und beim friseur für geimpfte
und genießen gibt es diese tests pflicht
nicht
alle in deutschland müssen erst einmal
weiter maske tragen in bus und bahn und
beim einkaufen das bleibt genau wie der
streit um die lagebeurteilung bund und
länder wollen laut beschluss künftig
nicht nur die sogenannte incidents im
auge haben sondern zum beispiel auch die
belastungen der kliniken wenn es darum
geht wie stark das leben in deutschland
eingeschränkt bleibt
als stückwerk kritisiert
linksfraktionschef bat die korona
beschlüsse weitere reaktionen aus den
parteien und eine zusammenfassung
treffens hat jetzt heike slansky für sie
nach zwei monaten pause einfach
sorgloser sommer heute das vorgezogene
treffen im kanzleramt angela merkel mit
den länderchefs hauptthema die impfquote
die zu niedrig sei er ist 55 prozent der
bevölkerung doppelt geschützt weit
entfernt von der gewünschten
herdenimmunität die nicht so gute
nachricht ist dass das impf tempo doch
erheblich nachgelassen hat und deshalb
sind wir uns einig dass jeder in seiner
verantwortung bund und länder aber auch
kommunale verantwortliche wo immer es
geht für das impfen werden weil es
einfach ein schutz für uns alle ist
unser normales leben kommt zurück durch
das impfen wer das impfen ausschlägt
läuft gefahr dass auf dauer dieses ganze
hin und her und dieses ganze theater mit
testen masken endlos raum der druck auf
die ungeimpften steigt ab dem 11 oktober
soll fast jeder der ein schnelltest
braucht selbst bezahlen ausgenommen
schwangere und kinder unter 12 man kann
all diese erfordernisse testen
kostenpflichtige test umgehen durch eine
impfung kann man sie umgehen wer dieses
angebot nicht annimmt kann nicht
dauerhaft damit rechnen dass die
solidargemeinschaft ihm das finanziert
also doch eine impfpflicht durch die
hintertür kritik von fdp und afd die
bundesregierung über zieht hier völlig
macht auch die bürger regelrecht panisch
damit möglichst viele das mittragen das
ist unnötig und es ist falsch hier darf
nicht der versuch unternommen werden
gewissermaßen über die ankündigung von
daumenschrauben die bereitschaft eine
impfung in anspruch zu nehmen erhöht
werden die vierte welle so die botschaft
rolle auf den herbst zu einen weiteren
locker und jedoch soll es nicht geben
chuck und alabama die aus unserem
hauptstadtstudio das treffen ging er
dieses erstaunlich schnell war die
einigkeit unter den
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsident
noch der kanzlerin so groß ja zumindest
bei den punkt druck auf ungeimpfte war
die einigkeit eben sehr groß da hat man
sich offensichtlich schnell geeinigt
anders sieht es aus bei der frage welche
kriterien eigentlich in zukunft
ausschlaggebend sein sollen für weitere
einschränkungen in der korona krise da
sind offensichtlich noch so viele fragen
offen gewesen dass also ein neuer corona
maßstab keinen eingang gefunden hat
dieses papier der ices das will man in
den nächsten wochen und monaten beraten
daran wird es sicherlich noch kritik
geben stattdessen setzt man jetzt eben
auf den genannten druck für ungeimpfte
man will auf eine gesamt impfquote in
der bevölkerung von 75 prozent kommen
das seien noch mal 15 bis 20
prozentpunkte mehr sagte die
bundeskanzlerin
heute und die maßnahmen die man sieht
kann man dann tatsächlich schon als
daumenschrauben verstehen außerdem
hätten bund und länder gerne eine
verlängerung der epidemischen lager von
nationaler tragweite dass es die
regelung die es ihnen über den elfter
september wenn die verlängerung kommen
würde hinaus erlauben würde weitere
bundesweite coroner regeln zu treffen
wenn das nötig sein sollte das muss
allerdings der bundestag beschließen und
da werden wir jetzt in den nächsten
tagen sicherlich sehen wie die
vorschläge aktuell ankommen und ob da
die bereitschaft dazu da ist auch
mitzugehen geschäfte dieser einordnung
von talabani und
ausführlich geht es hier gleich noch mal
um die korona beschlüsse direkt im
anschluss in einem zdf spezial
und bei dem bund länder treffen heute
ging es auch um die folgen der
flutkatastrophe um die kosten zu stemmen
soll es einen nationalen wiederaufbau
form geben und zwar in höhe von 30
milliarden euro
gut die hälfte davon soll vom bund
kommen der rest von den ländern mit dem
geld soll unter anderem möglichst
schnell wieder die zerstörte
infrastruktur aufgebaut werden die
schäden sind riesig wie julia schröter
aus dem urteil berichtet es sieht aus
wie in einem kriegsgebiet auch fast vier
wochen nach der verheerenden flut nacht
im besonders betroffenen aartal haben
tausende menschen ihr zuhause verloren
die infrastruktur völlig zerstört
einsatzkräfte arbeiten immer noch daran
zumindest das nötigste wieder in gang zu
bringen die stromversorgung ist
eingeschränkt möglich gasversorgung ist
noch nicht möglich und auch die
versorgung mit trinkwasser und auch das
abwasser systemen sind noch stark
angeschlagen und wir haben gerade quasi
wieder instand gesetzt um zumindest eine
notversorgung wir sicher zu stellen auf
der prioritätenliste ganz oben der
verkehr muss wieder rollen damit firmen
überall im tal ungehindert beim
wiederaufbau helfen können der
geschlossene fonds für die
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland pfalz
auch eine botschaft an die betroffenen
mit dieser zusage dass deutschland
gemeinsam steht bei dieser großen
nationalen herausforderung denke ich
sollte das auch ein signal sein an sie
alle dass man wirklich auch unter bereit
ist zu unterstützen und den wiederaufbau
für alle zu ermöglichen
wie wichtig hilfe von übergeordneter
ebene ist hatten zuletzt auch mehrere
arten bürgermeister wie alfred sebastian
deutlich gemacht in einem brandbrief an
die politik das braucht eine größere
nationale anstrengung weil die baufirmen
die sind in der struktur infrastruktur
gar nicht vorhanden ehe die müssen von
weiter her kommen und müssen hier in
einer großaktion hier die infrastruktur
wieder aufbauen es ist viel zu tun und
die zeit drängt noch ist sommer doch der
herbst naht heizungen und eine
funktionierende gasversorgung werden
dann am allerwichtigsten sein
fehlen geht das schicksal der menschen
in den flutgebieten sie wollen helfen
allein durch die zdf sammelaktion sind
dadurch mittlerweile rund 80 millionen
euro zusammen gekommen wenn auch sie
spenden wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein konto dafür
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser mehr
informationen gibt es unter spenden
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8
wer mit der deutschen bahn fahren will
muss sich auf verzögerungen einstellen
bereits ab heute abend will die
lokführergewerkschaft gdl streiken
zunächst im güterverkehr durch den
arbeitskampf streicht die bahn von
mittwoch bis donnerstag
drei viertel ihrer fernzüge streikende
freitagmorgen 2 uhr isabel de la vega
mit den einzelheiten
voller angriffslust verkündet der chef
der lokführergewerkschaft den
bevorstehenden streik ihn habe der bahn
konzern selbst verschuldet es ist das
management eines bundeseigenen
unternehmens das hier den arbeitskampf
im eisenbahnsystem provoziert 48 stunden
streik ab morgen früh um 2 die reisenden
müssen sich auf zugausfälle und
verspätungen einstellen also gerade weil
er alle die bahnen total ausgebucht ist
und so das haben wir jetzt gestreikt
deshalb auch für urlauber die gerade
innerhalb von deutschland urlaub machen
wenn dann ein paar züge fahren die dann
aber jetzt in der pandemie lage dann
gestoppt voll sind wenn da mal nichts
passiert wenn wir das recht haben warum
nicht
das recht mehr geld zu verlangen während
das angebot der bahn lohnsteigerungen
erst ab 2022 in höhe von 1,5 prozent
vorsieht und im folgenden jahr weitere
17 prozent fordert die gdl schon fürs
laufende jahr 1,4 prozent mehr lohn und
1,8 prozent für das jahr darauf sowie
eine corona prämie von 600 euro gerade
weil man mit der gesamtsumme nicht so
weit auseinander liege zeigt der
deutsche bahn konzern kein verständnis
für einen arbeitskampf und schon gar
nicht mitten in der hauptreisezeit
also es liegt alles auf dem tisch um zu
lösungen am verhandlungstisch bekommen
es ist völlig unnötig und völlig
überzogen in der form nun in streiks zu
geben für die bahn ist klar es geht hier
nicht nur ums geld sondern die frage
welche gewerkschaft im konzern künftig
das sagen hat und
am berliner hauptbahnhof ist für uns
stephan merseburger stefan was kommt auf
bahnreisende jetzt alles konkret zu
auch bahnreisende kommt eine ganze menge
zu nur ein viertel der züge das bedeutet
es wird ich habe tschuldigung ich muss
das hier raus nimmt das bedeutet es wird
erhebliche verzögerungen geben und
massive verspätungen bahnreisende
sollten sich unbedingt auf bahn de
informieren ob ihre züge nun fahren oder
nicht betroffen sind auch die s bahn das
heißt der berufsverkehr in den
ballungsgebieten
die bahn will sich kulant zeigen das
bedeutet dass tickets länger gelten und
auch dass man bei rückerstattungen
großzügig sein wird für den konzern
kommt dieser streik zur unzeit corona
hat für gigantische defizite gesorgt und
jetzt ist hauptreisezeit in elf
bundesländern sind sommerferien die gdl
sagt sie nehme darauf rücksicht um den
wochenend und reiseverkehr nicht allzu
stark zu belasten belasten endete dieser
streik in der nacht zum freitag um 2 uhr
doch das zeigen die erfahrungen der
letzten streiks bis sich die lage
normalisiert hat wird es später am
freitag reisende brauchen also richtig
gute nerven und richtig viel geduld
vielen dank stephan merseburger
nach schwerin dort hat die afg heute
offiziell ihren bundestagswahlkampf
gestartet zu der kundgebung vor dem
schweriner schloss kamen die beiden
spitzenkandidaten alles weidl und tino
kubala in mecklenburg vorpommern wird am
26 september parallel zum bundestag auch
ein neuer landtag gewählt im zdf
politbarometer liegt die fdp bundesweit
zuletzt bei 11 prozent
und jetzt schauen wir auf die
verheerenden feuer die zurzeit in
verschiedenen ländern wüten zuerst ein
blick nach griechenland
90.000 hektar sind er bereits verbrannt
eine fläche so groß wie berlin
dramatisch bleibt die lage auf euböa
griechenlands zweitgrößter insel
feuerwehrkräfte einwohner innen
freiwillige alle versuchen die brände
unter kontrolle zu bekommen der
regierung wird dabei vorgeworfen zu spät
löschflugzeuge geschickt zu haben
annette hilsenbeck und volker check
die fahrt durch den norden der insel ist
nichts für schwache nerven wer sich dem
dorf keramion hat der spürt noch die
gewaltige kraft des feuers das hierdurch
zog vieles muss abgerissen werden da
sind sich die einwohner sicher jannis
atanasio hat fast alles verloren und er
hat großen zorn weil auch die helfer vor
ort mit der situation überfordert waren
die feuerwehr stand hier und als sie
gesehen haben dass die flammen
übergriffe sind sie einfach weg gefangen
und haben uns alleingelassen
fast 900 feuerwehrleute und
katastrophenschützer sind inzwischen auf
euböa im einsatz aus aller herren länder
viele haben seit tagen nicht richtig
geschlafen alle leiden unter der
extremen hitze durch feuer und sonne sie
schlagen breite schneisen in den wald
viele geflüchtete die jetzt zurückkehren
stehen vor dem nichts denn sie haben mit
den pinienwäldern ihr geld verdient
angesichts der schäden die sie hier
vorfinden die verbrannten wälder von
denen sie bisher lebten steigt die wut
auf die regierung die habe viel zu spät
einsatzkräfte geschickt und damit alles
aufs spiel gesetzt
der ministerpräsident entschuldigte sich
gestern abend per tv ansprache
wir haben getan was menschenmöglich war
aber in einigen fällen war das nicht
genug
die griechische regierung hat am
nachmittag schnelle und unbürokratische
hilfe beim wiederaufbau beschlossen ob
sich dadurch die erhitzten gemüter
beruhigen wird sich in den nächsten
wochen zeigen
auch in den usa genauer im norden
kaliforniens brennt es ist das größte
feuer nde geschichte des bundesstaates
tausende menschen mussten fliehen
hunderte gebäude sind zerstört
die historische goldgräberstadt
greenville komplett abgebrannt rt wissen
berichtet sie würden es so gern
aufhalten wenn sie könnten aber der wind
verbreitet funken und flammen mit
rasender geschwindigkeit
das sogenannte dixie feuer frisst sich
durch kalifornien über 2.000
quadratkilometer und verschlingt dabei
historische orte die einstige
goldgräberstadt greenville die 1100
menschen hier konnten fliehen aber das
was ihr leben ausmachte ist zerstört
bob jones hat alles verloren der
78-jährige lebt jetzt in einem wohnwagen
die in ihm freunde gegeben haben
es kam so schnell man konnte nur noch
fliehen die zerstörung das bringt nicht
um wie soll ich in meinem alter noch mal
neu anfangen
er versucht es 15 mitglieder seiner
familie haben ihre häuser verloren
es sei überwältigend so viel zu tun sagt
er ich versuche mich auf das
naheliegendste zu konzentrieren
8500 feuerwehrleute bekämpften den
kalifornien insgesamt zehn waldbrände
auch im benachbarten bundesstaaten
brennt es der rauch zieht über fast 2000
kilometer bis denver colorado und den
kalifornien ist kein ende in sicht
temperaturen um 40 grad windböen wenn
das feuer den lassen nationalpark hier
durchquert hat sind weitere orte und
menschen bedroht wenn sie es nicht doch
irgendwie auffallen
der vorwurf gegen den gouverneur des us
bundesstaates new york steht schon
länger im raum andrew cuomo soll
ehemalige und aktuelle mitarbeiterinnen
sexuell belästigt haben jetzt ist der
druck zu groß geworden cuomo kündigte
seinen rücktritt an ein
untersuchungsbericht hält die
belästigungen bereits für erwiesen und
auch us-präsident beiden hatte cuomo
aufgefordert konsequenzen zu ziehen und
auch gegen einen weiteren prominenten
gibt es schwere vorwürfe
die amerikanerin virginia jeff ray wird
prinz andrew vergewaltigung vor und hat
in den usa jetzt klage gegen ihn
eingereicht sie erklärte prinz andrew
habe sie als damals 17 jährige mehrfach
zum geschlechtsverkehr gezwungen in
häusern und wohnungen des multi
millionärs und sexualstraftäters jeffrey
epstein auch apps 10 habe er sexuelle
gewalt angetan bisher haben sich prinz
andrew und das britische königshaus
nicht zu der klage äußern
willkommen zum sport zu norbert und zur
offiziellen vorstellung des neuen
bundestrainers und die fand
passenderweise auf der baustelle des
neuen dfb campus in frankfurt statt die
nationalmannschaft ist ja auch eine
baustelle nach der ära löw nachfolger
hansi flick und sein team wollen mit
neuer qualität und andere mentalität
zurück an die weltspitze
der neue baumeister werkelt an einem
team das früh die initiative ergreifen
soll wir wollen möglichst rollen kennt
er alle vom pokern ich setze hinweis der
hoffnung war ich glaube ich habe ja
alles dafür getan um den pott zu holen
um zu gewinnen alles abgeräumt hat er in
münchen champions league weltpokal
dfb-pokalsieg und zwei meisterschaften
das neue team wird bekannte gesichter
haben wenn die
trauma überwinden die besten werden
eingeladen und wenn sie wenn sie
topleistung abrufen wovon nicht ausgehen
dass sie das noch können dann dann sind
sie auch ein teil dieser mannschaft
besonders für heu ist so flick und
vielleicht auch für mario götze den held
von rio stehe die tür offen
am wochenende beginnt die fußball
bundesliga heute hat die bund länder
konferenz beschlossen bei
sportveranstaltungen mit mehr als 5000
zuschauern soll die zulässige auslastung
auf maximal 50 prozent der höchste
kapazität begrenzt werden aber nicht
mehr als 25.000 zuschauer der
sechsmalige weltfußballer lionel messi
steht offenbar ganz kurz vor dem wechsel
zum fc barcelona vom fc barcelona zu
paris st germain nach seiner
tränenreichen abschieds pressekonferenz
am sonntag in spanien heute seine
fröhliche ankunft in frankreich zum
medizincheck
er ist da wahrhaftig was seit tagen ja
nicht nur die pariser spatzen von den
dächern pfeifen ist nun wirklich
eingetreten der nächste hochkaräter im
ohnehin schon üppig besetzten
starensemble von paris anna zusammen mit
seiner familie hatte der 34 jahre alte
argentinier am nachmittag barcelona
verlassen sehr emotional dort der
abschied nach zwei überaus erfolgreichen
jahrzehnten bei psg soll er noch am
abend den medizincheck absolvieren die
offizielle vorstellung dann morgen und
zwar nicht wie ursprünglich allen
ernstes geplant am eiffelturm sondern
eine nummer kleiner
im stadion
morgen um 11 uhr wissen wir mehr
dankeschön die zeichen stehen auf sommer
nach letzten schauern und gewittern
setzt sich morgen fast überall die sonne
durch und wo es schon morgen führt 30
grad reicht erklärt gleich katja
horneffer claus kleber begrüßt sie hier
um kurz vor 10 uhr beim heute-journal
und wir sagen auf wiedersehen machen sie
es gut
[Musik]
auch heute zogen vor allen dingen über
den westen den norden und die mitte
deutschlands einige regenschauer und
gewitter hinweg sie sehen das ganz gut
an dieser violetten farbe in
süddeutschland dagegen blieb es trocken
da schien häufig die sonne aber jetzt in
der nacht sind in niederbayern einige
gewitter nicht ganz ausgeschlossen über
norddeutschland ziehen die regenschauer
ostwärts ab bei westwind die
temperaturen sinken hier östlich von
münchen oder auch am oberrhein 15 grad
an den küsten von nord- und ostsee sind
es um die 14 sonst meist 13 bis 10 grad
und morgen bleibt es an den küsten am
kühlsten dort erwarten uns 22 grad sonst
sind es 23 bis 24 grad im süden und im
südwesten geht es auf sommerliche 25 bis
30 grad drauf und das wird morgen ein
sehr freundlicher tag sonne und wolken
wechseln sich ab in norddeutschland sind
die wolken auch mal etwas dichter und
schleswig holstein kann es mal für einen
kleinen regenschauer bei westwind
reichen in den nächsten tagen gibt's
wirkliches sommerwetter donnerstag und
freitag bringen und 22 bis 31 grad am
freitag kann es dann vielleicht schon
mal ein erstes kleines hitze gewitter
geben am alpenrand der samstag bringt
dann von nordwesten etwas kühlere
temperaturen genannt